you've the style of a super villain from
uh James Bond movie I'm sorry you look
like a super villain from a I've heard
this before
yeah I don't have that evil streak
though you look like you're the guy in
the mountains who's plotting yeah I know
some European evil yeah yeah something
yeah but you've been told this before
yeah I've been told before yeah I don't
have I don't have the personality for it
however you
do we'd be a good team together you and
me yes we're both so tall that would
look nice I know give me a can
impressive uh couple walking into a
party right
yeah we can be like who can we take
advantage of
here come hither we'd be a hit we'd be a
real
hit all right goddess sea
got a sea you are a dominatrix I am here
in Los
Angeles you've uh you've been doing this
for how long going on 26 years
now where did this where did this is it
a fetish it's a fetish right uh it's a
lifestyle for me where where did this
lifestyle come from do you think was it
something you were exposed to or
something no no I'm supposed to be an
Academia I'm supposed to be a
criminology professor
um but life is interesting that way when
I
was really young I think this stuff is
hardwired into a person just like a a
sexual identity so I
identify with with kink like Norm normal
things hold
this vanilla vanilla things just for
you when I was a kid The Old Woman Who
Lived in a Shoe it's a story in mother
hubard she had so many kids she didn't
know what to do she gave them some broth
without any
bread gave them a spanking and sent them
to bed and so the illustration at the
time is something that they wouldn't
show now it was this lady and she had
this the child over her lap and she was
spanking it and you could see the Bare
Bum and it was red and the child was
crying and I was just like
Intoxicated by this picture it was like
it was like a drug to I was in the
backseat of these long car trips and I
just be staring at this mother Hub like
it was porn for me I was I didn't know
what it was but I was always interested
in bums and spanking and I was always
trying to come up with reasons why some
someone in my neighborhood should be
spanked and so you find me in the forest
with some kid over a log and some
switches that I'd made and be whacking
them and I was always let's play house
but somehow that there was this
punishment with the spanking like bums
always did it for me and um and then at
school I I tell the story on my
website
about being in in school and there's
this bully named Charlie and he was mean
to other kids and so I had a group of
girlfriends our little gang and we
cornered Charlie and we tied him to a
tree and of course I pulled down his
pants and whipped him and this is all
very inappropriate by the way one
shouldn't do these things this is a
story about the past and so I wouldn't
do that now of course to unless it was
to an adult but um so we would make a
game of finding Charlie and capturing
him and tying him up and somehow he
became very available and he'd walk home
from school very
slowly and uh so that's that is what I
mean by being hardwired for this you
don't think it came from any thing that
you went through as a kid no because
children's book children's
story like I I wasn't exposed to
anything no abuse in your childhood from
your parents no um we would be driving
the countryside and I'd see a house and
I'd start fantasizing about well what if
that house had like a secret room and in
that room would be spanking equipment
and there would be these things going on
so it's it's like it's TI hardwired in
you yeah so it's without even being
exposed to World of Kink how do you
explain that when you're nine8 10 is
there anyone in your family that has a
similar
inclination I don't think
so you're 6' five which makes it even
more impressive
right and that uh that makes you a an
imposing
Dom and you're a sub you have uh Mike
here this is slave Mike yep he's been uh
he's been your sub for how long um he's
been my sub for about five years I have
another who I've seen for 20
years and these relationships are
sexual no um in the Kink world when
you're an old school top as I am it's
not about vanilla things like sex it's
more about our
relationship come lie down in front of
me I see you're fidgeting lay on your
back
it's more
about we express our pleasure in
different
ways and I control him he spends time
with me he's my lifestyle sub so he's my
gopher he's my Confidant he helps me out
in whatever I need um whether it's
showing up for things like this today or
just being my errand boy my someone I
can just direct around and but also play
with the in a lifestyle relationship
it's about more than just playing in a
dungeon is there a romantic aspect to it
though I I adore him he adores
me
um I consider him a partner mhm yeah but
you are clearly the
dominant person in the relationship yes
in in every way too right not just yeah
although that's not to
his feelings matter to me I don't abuse
him when they're when he's unhappy I
don't like that so it's like any
relationship you try to hear what the
other person is saying
and when I am wrong I apologize I try to
do right by him CU he sacrifices a lot
for me and so there is respect there I
respect his boundaries I also push his
boundaries I push him pretty hard
in a lot of ways but he needs to be
treated well also you care for him I do
yeah he's my prize
possession I'd like to thank better help
for being a sponsor of today's video I
think a lot of my viewers are going
through things just like we all are
whether you're a viewer or not of this
channel I think everybody goes through
something and whether it's depression or
anxiety or you're just going through a
tough period of your life talking with a
professional can be really helpful you
know personally I go through just the
stress of talking to so many people that
are going through tough times tough
tough stories is hard on me and and
talking with the therapist is really
helpful so I I just started doing that
recently it's been really great for me
I'm I'm a huge fan of therapy and with
better help you can have your therapy
session as a phone call or a video
session or even messaging if you prefer
whatever is most comfortable for you I
did mine as as video which is great it's
it's just like being in their office but
you're doing it from the comfort of your
own
home and my better help therapist has
been wonderful right right from the
get-go he he kind of figured out what my
what my deal is and was really helpful
and what's great about better help is
you get paired with a therapist you're
matched within 48 hours in most cases if
you're just not feeling it with your
therapist you can try another one or you
can try as many times as you like until
you find someone that you're comfortable
with and you can do that no additional
charge which is really nice so if you'd
like to join the over four million
people that have taken charge of their
mental health by talking with an
experienced Better Health therapists you
can actually get 10% off by going to
betterhelp.com
softwhite underbelly or click on the
link in the video description box below
I suspect that in some way on the
surface it looks like you are clearly in
charge you are the one that runs the
show you're in charge of this what's
what goes on in this relationship but
it's almost like and maybe we'll have
some questions for Mike
later like
he might actually
hold the like be be kind of he has a lot
of lot more control than you would think
he he is very clever because he has made
himself invaluable to me he is not
easily replaceable like on FetLife where
we met um there are lots of people who
want to be my
sub but having a sub is like having a
pet you got to take care of a pet and
this pet learned how to do things for me
that I need so I would be at a lot
without him running my social media and
all all these other things that I've
come to rely upon him for
so I think he he did well in learning
what makes me tick and so I would just
be devastated to to lose someone of his
value because submission is a gift that
you give
someone you're not entitled to it
they're not crap
I value him and what he gives me and so
he needs to be treated well in return
and what he means by being treated well
is maybe being trampled by me or just
being paid attention to but I want to
disabuse you of the notion that Subs are
just treated like garbage because they
are not we can't have one without the
other right I am not powerful without a
person being subjugating themselves to
me it is consent that makes the whole
thing
go you know I'm sure there's lots of
squares watching this and thinking this
is just the weirdest [__] ever what do
you think people don't understand about
this
lifestyle well first of all I don't care
if uh if people think this is weird
because this is what works for me and
and so I try to go through life um being
open to other people and trying to give
trying to hear them but I have learned
that
people people have to be
open-minded to understand what I do and
if they just think that's weird then
it's not up to me to defend myself or my
lifestyle um it's just here I am like I
am and
so this is a relationship that lasts
longer than many vanilla relationships
and it works because of consent and it
works because of love and trust and
great communication great communication
I've learned yeah so many of the fetish
uh interviews I've done and I've done a
lot now the one thing that really
impresses me with all of them is the
level of communication and and
intelligence amongst the people I've
interviewed is like unmatched I think
emotional intelligence as well as
intelligence I find
saposexual people are a turn on for me
but also emotional intelligence means
taking a step back listening to what the
other person is
saying and just hearing them I think
people need to be
heard and in this sort of relationship
it's really important to see people
value who they are hear what they need
and then when I have that information
then I can exploit it and push their
boundaries but first to assess who they
are what they're ready for what they
need to be pulled back
from and uh yeah it should be fun
ultimately life is should be fun and
when we were young kids we played a lot
and then as you get older people you
know become serious and kind of beaten
down by life a little bit and they
restricted restricted and they're not
they're not doing things like role play
at home which is one of the things I
love um they're worried about pleasing
others pleasing their parents pleasing
whoever yeah and it's so
constraining
expectations and I I suspect that people
in this in these
lifestyles are probably some of the most
fulfilled satisfied people in our
society and but at the same time it's
hard to Le lead this lifestyle you have
to have emotional stamina and fortitude
when you when you're
misunderstood so that's been something
that I've had to be okay with as being
an
outlier
yeah yeah that that that's that goes
without saying doesn't it this um are
there so you had many you've had more
than Mike as a sub what what have you
learned about men
from interacting with them in this way
um I love men I find them fascinating I
like playing with them um I'll always
love men I think men over 40 tend to be
more confident I am noticing um an
interesting Trend in that younger men
these days are exploring more and
getting over themselves but it takes a
while for men to relax into letting go
of patriarchal
views and when they do I can see the
relief flood over them just to
relinquish control and to be free to not
have to be this thing that society says
but to give them a safe space to play
and a place where they don't have to be
judged where if they want to dress up
and like a girl I approve it and just to
feel like it's okay like someone's not
going to just be disgusted with them
it's it's valuing them as a person
that's hearing what they need I see
myself as a Healer of sorts yeah is
being a
sub in some ways a release or an escape
from the responsibility that that a sub
might have at work he's where he's the
boss he's in charge everyone's dependent
on him to make every decision or he's
responsible for many people and this is
like a
and an escape from that a release
absolutely I think men um are often
sometimes just because of the way our
society is structured they're always in
charge and they're always taking care of
other people and sometimes women yes but
with the
patriarchal Notions about how men should
be men and you know their views that of
that are still held of women too um but
when you're a powerful person you're
always taking Tak care of other people
and so when you can be a sub it's like
someone is taking care of you they're
listening to what your needs are and to
give them a space where someone can take
care of them and they don't have to make
any choices is tremendously
freeing do do you think this lifestyle
is mostly about
control what what is the no I think it's
it's about just whatever
the whatever the fetish is it's not
necessarily about control it's just
having a platform where you have a safe
space to discuss your likes without
judgment that doesn't mean I'll always
like what other people do and there are
plenty people I don't want to play with
um it's not necessarily about control
though when I'm topping I'm the boss
right it's my games my house my rules
don't like it go away right it it sounds
like this was in your personality even
as a young
girl yes is there ever a part of your
personality where you are not looking to
be in charge be the Dom um just because
I'm a Dom doesn't mean I go to the
checkout counter and boss people around
I'm a humble person respectful
absolutely yeah there's a time and a
place for everything and I I tend to
judge people based on how they treat
others if if you're rude to the waiter
I'm not going to like
that yeah I I believe in treating people
well yeah you know looking at you the
way you're dressed the way you're
behaving with with your sub you would
get the impression you're just
a a force to that will never no one will
ever get over on you but you're a person
too I am but I mean that's even though I
talk about respect I can be a bit
Mercurial so I am a bit of a demon but I
try to reain it back have you ever had
what we would call vanilla relationships
before you got into this lifestyle I
have and I found it challenging in a
number of ways um people weren't open
they didn't understand things like
roleplay like why do we have to be
different people
and um so I I found
it difficult to have intimacy because
I'd have to escape in my head because
they weren't comfortable trying things
and so that ultimately led to the
breakup or just and then when I was in
the
lifestyle people who were
straighter so-called
um they just
couldn't deal with all this mhm so yeah
what do you think people that don't
understand this lifestyle
would would misunderstand about a sub
you you would look at at at Mike and
you'd say oh my God he's such a it's
such a humiliating situation he's in
it's just it's degrading it's like but
look how much attention he's getting and
he gets to hang out with me what could
be better than that I don't let just any
person come and spend like 3 weeks with
me coming up and serving me breakfast
and hanging out we're together a lot and
wouldn't you like to be with me I'm fun
you look fun and he gets to dress this
way and yeah but you're not dressed this
way all the time you're not all the time
but uh he wears a collar he does my
bidding like what else would you rather
be doing
right what's not to like like you enjoy
this lifestyle
indeed absolutely
indeed how extreme does your uh um I
don't want to say punishment but
your your interactions with with your
subs get well in my when in my personal
life playing I express my
displeasure quite
vociferously so I find that Subs tend to
do boneheaded things so I'm going to
have a comment about that some things
are not acceptable and you you can't
anticipate some things that Subs would
do so sometimes I get so annoyed with
them and so they need to hear it and
they need to be punished and we try to
think of ways like how can we prevent
this from happening again like how can I
help you help me help you not do this
again and sometimes I think well the
best way is a painful reminder so let's
go to the kitchen let me just pull out
whatever wooden spoon I have bend over
drop your pants and let's try to
remember these details like whatever it
is to to hone in this little accident
and
reminder right Mike yes mistress
[Music]
yeah SP your
looks in your romantic life this this
overlaps with that or is it separate
from this um well my slaves are my
slaves but in my life outside the scene
I'm still in the scene so I I need kinky
people yeah it's how I'm
wired have you had other
careers um I was a grocery clerk once
and a produce
manager uh I studied criminology applied
science I have a BFA and an MFA so I'm
also a painter how how do you discover
this
lifestyle um so I played professional
basketball in Europe and when I finished
I had an Achilles injury back then and I
got a call from this agent i' had once
worked for doing modeling in La about
being on the Mory poit show in New York
City and they were doing a show on
opposite
attractions and I had to say that I
really enjoyed shortman which I have an
affinity for so I came to New York to do
the talk show and I thought well my
basketball career is over maybe I could
stay in New York and I tried to get a
job U via my criminology degree and they
just looked at my uh resume and said why
would you want to work here so no one
was hiring and at the time there were
the Yellow Pages if you remember those I
was fling what am I going to do like I
was living by the skin of my teeth in
New York City right that's not a good
place to have no money and I came across
this page for
Domination from the Terrell Institute uh
which was a famous place at the time for
Domination and I called up and explained
that I was new in the city and the head
mistress Ava Terrell said oh no no we
have everyone we need we don't need
anybody and I said did I mention I'm 6'5
she said oh you must come down
immediately and that was so lucky for me
because she took me under her Wing she
taught me the correct way to top cuz you
can get sucked into the CD underbelly of
things in in New York City and um she
was this fantastic Mentor for me and
from her I learned the ropes and um my
career proceeded from then you had you
had someone to teach you that teach you
how to yes she was very wise um very she
was the daughter of a prince she was a
film star in Mexico she was just
fantastic in so many ways and I was
really lucky because um she was just so
smart and just she was at the at the the
very high end of things and so I learned
what could be done and how people should
be treated and one of the things that
she taught me was that people who are
happy with their sex life or with their
fetish life or with their fantasy life
will be more fulfilled people overall in
their whole life absolutely so when when
we are fulfilled in some way that like
just affects everything in life and it's
important and um
it should be sought after people should
be happy this way think of how marriages
collapse because they don't people don't
feel free to express what they like and
they have affairs and they F split apart
from their spouse because you just
there's a breakdown in communication and
people stop playing and that's sex and
intimacy rather is the glue that can
hold Rel relationship together right it
can smooth over those little hurts bring
you closer to your partner you can just
you can cry you can laugh but when you
when you're like physically distant from
your significant other then just things
you don't have that relationship like
you first may have when you first got
involved and this sort of play is
infinite because you can keep pushing
your boundaries you can keep exploring
one of the things that I really like is
roleplay so you don't have to be
yourself you can be riding on your
stationary bike you know and your spouse
can come arrest you for speeding things
like that like I play games like that
it's it's about keeping the fun alive
and I think this lifestyle is a good way
to just get the most out of life we're
here for such a short time like let's
let's have fun let's do something let's
not just get grounded down you know you
just found a very unique way of making
the the
relationship you know refreshing for
both people I'm a vessel from God and
this is my personal way to make the
world better whether it's kicking men in
the
balls um putting them in their place
dressing them up as women I believe this
is this is what I was meant to do what
were your parents like uh they're AC
academics
yeah but there was no particularly
unusual personality there um I was
raised with almost Victorian standards
of
propriety on one side and then kind of
a
dominant uh big figure on the other side
with a larger temper and I think that
flip-flop uh somehow manifested itself
in me me in
um in a very curious
way may I ask your sub a few questions
sure um might get up on your
knees come back
here is that comfy for you yes mistress
okay so Mike you
uh you have had careers professional
careers yes I have I'm a I'm a retired
computer systems
analyst and was your previous career was
one where you were kind of in charge you
had a lot of
responsibility you had you know a a lot
of power yes I have managed
teams small to medium teams of
people and and this relationship is kind
of an escape from
those um
those those that role that you had um
the role that I had at work doesn't
really have anything to do with this
I've been wired this way since my early
early 20s really yes but what was your
childhood like um it was your typical
70s family my father was in
charge um we just I don't know it's just
like a typical family mhm nothing
particularly unusual no abuse nothing
like that nothing like that no I mean
you'd get spanked when you did something
wrong but that was it that was it can I
inject I noticed that you ask about
abuse um did you see 50 Shades of Gray I
never saw it okay well there's sometimes
this notion that people who are in this
scene there's something in their past
where they've been harmed in some way
that's that's the Assumption a lot of
people will make yeah yeah no and I
think like we're not necessarily sure
there are people who are messed up in
the scene but they're messed up people
everywhere but you don't have to have
abuse in your past to be
interested in deviant
things yeah I believe that yeah yeah
even though so many people that come
from abuse end
up
finding very alternative relationships
yeah there's also people who come from
very normal ones who uh take the same
route so Mike you you enjoy this
relationship very much it seems like I
do and by the way I was never abused as
a child yeah we we made that clear but
um yeah I enjoy this lifestyle
tremendously what what's your favorite
thing about your your
mistress oh
my she when I was when I was first
exploring this in my 20s and 30s my
ideal mistress was 6 and 1/2 ft tall and
muscular dominant and I never thought
I'd find such a
woman
um and I've seen how tall are you Mike
I'm 5'9 5'9 and I've seen
more Mistresses than I can count and
when I finally found her my search was
over yeah I believe that I flew from
Toronto to Vancouver to see her for the
first time
and I had never done that
before and that was it as soon as I met
her in person I knew
it like we had communicated for four or
five months before the meeting but after
after the first meeting it's like yes
she's the
one and the way
she I mean what what is how would you
describe what she does to you when you
guys are interacting with with in this
in this lifestyle is it degrading you is
it um demean I mean it's not degrading I
mean you can ask when you're playing
it's like sometimes you'll ask if I have
a request you know I can ask for
humiliation but in in normal day-to-day
life no she treats me with a lot of
respect and care and
love and what we do in our
private time playtime I keep private
yeah that's not to say also that when he
screws up that I don't degrade him would
you say that I can be quite
outspoken oh yes very I I don't reel in
my temper sometimes for people that I'm
really involved with like I can let
loose is that not true yes
M then I say o you okay
yes is is is your mistress a a caring
person
she's very caring she's very firm but
and fair but she's also very loving and
very caring but she's the boss oh
definitely she's the
boss uh and mistress have you had Subs
like a new sub who has a special request
of something he a particular particular
treatment he would like uh yeah they all
have interesting requests some from the
standard to the
but but what is the standard the
standard is um so I'm really good at
physically dominating I have a black
Belton Jiu-Jitsu and so I learned that I
really like to work with my body to
oppress shall we say and so I'm very
Hands-On like I like to touch and grab
and do things with my body instead of
directing people do this do that but to
make them but I had this one uh Playmate
in New York who wanted to show me he
said may I show you something I always
wanted to be a mother this was a a
man so I said okay by all means so he uh
went and squatted in the corner and out
popped a doll that he had inserted and
um he gave birth uh in my play Space to
this I was like congratul ations you're
you're a mother so I mean you do come
across a a wide variety of interesting
people what kind of things do you guys
get into just what is a typical thub
thing where
you humiliating
you're physically bossing him around
you're pushing um not necessarily
humiliating it has to be tailored
specifically because some people would
be triggered by being hum humiliated
right and it's not necessarily about
humiliation but exploring a fetish
together like the way stockings feel or
how it feels to wear a negl or satin and
then to we could both be wearing satiny
outfits and admiring um how someone
looks and high heels and objectifying
them and making them feel sexy other
people uh want things like to feel the
power of a woman and so I would have the
shock and a approach of getting them
down to the wrestling mat and choking
them and doing triangles and putting the
fear of God in them so do you have a
dungeon um I use a space in LA and San
Diego MH
yeah Mike and uh got s what would you
say I'll ask you these questions
separately Mike what what would you say
is the most important thing you've
learned from this
lifestyle um do your research if you're
looking for a new mistress make sure
that
she's it's going to be a safe experience
and always communicate what your limits
are and have a safe word and out so that
something
that's going south on you in a hurry you
can tap out or use a safe word and just
keep it safe and
insane excellent and and got s what
would you say is the most important
thing you've
learned in life or in this lifestyle I I
think that the skill set I've learned in
the lifestyle has transferable elements
to the real world like expressing
boundaries when something isn't right um
women have often had a hard time
expressing things and don't express
things right away when something isn't
right um especially when it comes to men
and learning how to say
no no stop that's not correct back off
or
just expressing boundaries in general is
something that um will serve you well
regardless of your gender absolutely
yeah that's an important thing for a lot
of people to
understand excellent all right godess
sea and Mike thank you so much for
sharing your story you guys have a
wonderful weekend thanks for having us
are amazing thank
you thank
you